united kingdom right now yesterday we
delivered
529 119
vaccinations more than half a million
and that means that today
exactly 100 days since margaret keenan
got that first authorized jab in the
whole world
we have now vaccinated over 25 million
people
across the united kingdom it's been such
a national mission
one of the biggest logistical exercises
since the war
and i've had the honor of playing
my part we've had the honor of playing
our parts it's been a
huge team effort and i've got absolutely
no doubt it's the
it it's the best project i've ever been
involved in and i want to say a huge
thank you to everybody
who lent in and has done so much
to put this country in the position
we're in where we've been able
and to vaccinate almost half of the
adult population
25 million people
and i think that it's nothing that any
of us
who've been involved in it from the
start will ever forget but what really
matters
is why this is making a difference and
we have some very exciting
information for you today about the real
world impact
that the vaccination rollout is having
if we could have the first
the slide please this slide shows over
time
the increase in the proportion of people
who actually have covered 19 antibodies
those are the antibodies that are so
crucial in our ability to fight the
disease
this chart isn't measuring how many
vaccines have been done
it's actually measuring the proportion
of people
who have the covert fighting antibodies
swimming around in their bloodstream
this chart represents
the fact that the vaccine is giving the
country
protection and as you can see
it runs up to the start of march
and it shows around 90 percent
of people age around 70 and above
at that point had these antibodies
and it has continued to expand further
in the two weeks or so since then
the chart explains why deaths from covid
in this country are now thankfully
falling so fast
they're down by over a third in the last
week
again and the vaccine is saving
thousands of lives right now here in the
uk
and it can give us all hope and
professor van tam is going to say
a little more about this and the safety
details in a second
and all of this underlines how important
it is that when you get the call
get the jab i find this data really
compelling
and to anybody who still has concerns or
any doubt about getting the jab
we know that the vaccine is safe
and helps make you safe it gives you
this protection
and dr mary ramsey is with us because
she's going to set out details of
a publication that public health england
have just released
with more evidence of the impact of the
vaccine to show
what this protection is like and that
shows that after a single dose of the
vaccine
either vaccine protection against
covid19
is around 60 percent that's protection
against getting it
protection against hospitalization is
around 80 percent and protection
against death is around 85 percent
and one of the other interesting facts
that is really important is that the
vaccine offers protection to you but it
also protects offers protection to those
around you and the data show
that if you live with someone who's been
vaccinated you have a 30 percent lower
risk
of catching covid19 yourself
this is the first data that directly
measures the impact of the vaccine on
reducing transmission
and it shows that the vaccines are
saving lives
both vaccines being rolled out in the uk
are not just safe but they make you safe
they're saving lives
and protecting people and because we're
rolling out
so fast and because we've protected so
many people so quickly
we're now able to extend the offer of a
vaccination to get
more people all people age 50 and above
are from today invited to come forward
and get a jam
the nhs will contact you and today we're
sending over
two million texts and letters and
invitations to get vaccinated anyone
aged 50 and over can now sign up on the
nhs.uk website
or call 119 we're on track to offer a
first dose to everyone in priority
groups 1 to 9 by the 15th of april
while we deliver on that commitment we
also
want to ensure that this offer reaches
everyone
in groups one to nine so
at the same time as opening up
offers of vaccinations to all those who
are 50 or above
we're going to do whatever it takes to
reach all those in the most vulnerable
groups who haven't come forward yet
before we move on to the next cohort
which is people in their 40s
so my message to our huge team of
vaccinators
is let's keep getting the numbers
through the doors
but it's absolutely critical that we
reach out
and we loop back and we invite in yet
again
all those who are in vulnerable groups
who haven't yet been vaccinated
i want to get those percentages of the
people in vulnerable groups
the percentages who've been vaccinated i
want to get them right up
reaching every last vulnerable person
and it is worth that
extra effort and we'll do that before we
move on to people in their 40s
now i'm 42 and i'm as eager as anyone
to get the jam but before we forge ahead
i want us to be confident
that we've done everything we can to
protect those most
in need of protection and we will do
all we can and do everything necessary
to secure the supplies
that are contractually committed to
protecting people in this
country so we're moving in the right
direction
thanks to everybody following the rules
that are keeping us safe now and thanks
to everybody coming forward
to get a jab that will keep us safe
for the future now is not the time to
waver
we're on the road to recovery the
vaccine is our way out
we are on track so let's stick with it
follow the rules
and when you get the call get the jab
i'm now going to ask mary to set out
more details
of that excellent data on the
effectiveness of the two vaccines
thank you um i'd just like to start by
adding my thanks to secretary of state
to the thousands of people who've been
involved in making this program a
success
from the scientists who produce the
vaccine from the people who make sure
the vaccine gets to the right places
those
injecting people every day and all the
people behind the scenes who are doing
all the planning and
and coordination it's really been a
great effort
um and i've worked in immunization for
30 years in in uk
and this is the largest and most uh fast
delivered
but in the most speed i've ever been
involved in it really is a great credit
to the public health system in this
country
around a month ago we published our
first data showing the
effectiveness of the vaccine and
today we've published an update on that
and the good news is
that uh things are continuing to show
that this
these vaccines are effective
uh there's we're showing good protection
in the over 70s
we've compared individuals who test
positive to individuals who test
negative and shown that there is a 60
reduction in your chance of catching
covid
if you are over 70 and have been
vaccinated
with both vaccines and those effects
are maintained for several weeks they
don't go away
they're still there even after a single
dose
and then you get additional protection
from the second dose
on top of that even if you do get
covid having been vaccinated our data
shows that your risk
of requiring hospital admission is
reduced by a further
40 percent based on whether you've had
either the astrazeneca vaccine
or the fisa vaccine and when you put
those two figures together
that means that in the over 80s we are
preventing
80 of hospital admissions it's 80
protection against
admissions we have a little bit longer
data for the visor vaccine and again
if you have a quartz covid despite being
vaccinated and have had a single dose of
fisa vaccine
what we have shown is that your chance
of dying from the infection
is reduced by 54 so really a very
a big additional reduction and again if
you put that together
with the protection that you're getting
against infection in the first place
that means that there's almost 85
percent
protection against dying with a single
dose of the vaccine
and again we see better figures after
the second dose
uh on top of that uh our data in
healthcare workers has shown that
healthcare workers who are vaccinated
have a 70 reduction in their risk of
getting infected
after a single dose and that's whether
they are a symptomatic case
or an asymptomatic case and that means
they are therefore
less likely to spread to vulnerable
individuals that they care for
and the really exciting data that came
from scotland last week
suggested that those vaccinated
healthcare workers have a 30
chance lower chance of passing infection
onto their
household contacts as secretive states
already mentioned
so this is really the first evidence we
have of a reduction in transmission
from vaccinating and it means that the
more people we vaccinate
the more we are going to be able to
reduce the spread of infection
so uh overall this is really now
translating into seeing a decline
in deaths and serious cases from this
infection
and it means every day we vaccinate more
people we are preventing more deaths
so uh i think we also
know as i think we've seen the antibody
data we've done a study today again
which shows that 75 percent of that
older group have protection and
immunity in their blood so again very
good
results so overall we will expect to see
as more people are vaccinated
a bigger impact on cases on
hospitalizations
and on deaths so i just use this
opportunity to encourage anybody who's
eligible for vaccine to come forward to
take the vaccine
both vaccines work incredibly
effectively i myself had astrazeneca
vaccine on friday
and i'm very pleased that i'm now
hopefully as well protected as the
people we've been studying
thank you thank you very much dr ramsey
professor bantam
thank you secretary of state good
afternoon um
i don't mind repeating my thanks on top
of everybody else's
to the nhs teams who day after day
continue with the vaccination program
it's a real tribute to their
perseverance and determination
that they do so and i feel very
privileged to occasionally be able to
stand alongside them and
help out in the vaccine centers
as the secretary of state has announced
we are now into the last
um cohort of the phase one program
it's important we get that done properly
before we
move on to phase two because phase one
uh is where the patients are who suffer
the mortality and you know
a bit like a football game where the
strikers
who score the wonder goals are the ones
who make the headlines
actually the hard yards are done by the
defenders and by the defensive
midfielders tracking back
tracking back for 90 minutes of the
whole game
watching everybody's back and this is
what it's going to be about now
tracking back and making sure that we
finish the job
properly in the phase one cohorts before
we move on
that high uptake is really really
important
i will turn now and spend um a few
moments
addressing what has clearly been a very
important and topical
media story in the last few days which
is about
vaccine safety and in particular
the the the
events in europe relating to the
astrazeneca vaccine
and the stories about blood clots
so where i will begin is that
with the european medicines agencies
spokesperson
themselves and their statement this is
the european medicines regulator
our equivalent of the mhra in europe
there is no indication
that vaccination has caused these
conditions
we are still firmly convinced that the
benefits of the az vaccine
in preventing covid19 outweigh
the risks of side effects and i think
that's really important to emphasize
that that is the official position of
the european regulator
as it is the official position of our
regulator
the mhra but behind the scenes
there is a lot of work going on to look
at
whether there is a signal in relation to
what we call venous thromboembolic
events clots
vte for short and there's a lot of
evidence emerging now that is reassuring
that there is no overall excess signal
or increased risk and i expect
without prejudice to their absolute
findings those to be the final
conclusions of the ema and the mhra
in due course so no no evidence
of increased risk but as you heard from
professor ramsey
a lot of evidence that the vaccine is
actually
saving lives and that's the really
important thing
that we push on with this
and i think from the enthusiasm of the
patients
i've vaccinated i see the enthusiasm of
the british people
to push on with this because vaccines
don't save lives
if they're in fridges they only save
lives if they're in
arms and that's a really important fact
all medicines have side effects
and all medicines have benefits and
that's the whole point that you
have to look at both sides and say how
big are the benefits in relation to the
risks
so even something really simple like
paracetamol
and here's a data sheet from a box of
paracetamol
the rare side effects are allergic
reactions such as skin rash mouth sores
fever difficulty breathing more prone to
bleeding bruising fever infections
nausea sudden weight loss loss of
appetite
jaundice yellowing of the eyes and skin
those are documented
rare side effects of paracetamol but we
all
understand the benefits of them and this
is no different a situation
that there's no proven association
with the blood clots and we have very
clear evidence
that these vaccines are beneficial and
save lives from what is otherwise
for some people particularly the ones we
are targeting
a potentially lethal disease i'll stop
there secretary of state
thank you very much jbt and we'll now go
to questions from the public
and then questions from the media the
first question
is from lynn from newcastle
will shielding end on march the 31st i'm
lucky enough to have had both my fires
of vaccinations
and i would like to return to work as a
nurse in the nhs will this be possible
on april the 1st
yes it will at lin i'm delighted to say
that
shielding will be able to end on the
31st of march
and i'm absolutely delighted that we'll
be able to welcome you back
into the nhs as a nurse and we all know
how important it is to get more nurses
into the nhs and getting you back
will be a very very important step so
i'm delighted you've had
both of your vaccines i hope you've
heard from
dr ramsey just how effective they
are and uh it's uh it's it's great news
that uh you'll be uh we'll be inviting
you back that's fantastic
thank you very much indeed uh sarah from
wiltshire
uh has sent a question in and the
question is in the united states
vaccinated people can meet indoors with
other vaccinated people
or with others where there is low risk
what are the plans to adopt similar
measures in the uk
and at what point will it be deemed to
be safe for social distancing among
vaccinated adults
to be no longer necessary well this is a
really
really important question and the
approach we're taking in the uk
sarah is that we're going to take the
steps together
down the road map because it's not
possible to vaccinate everybody at once
we've been taking a clinically advised
priority in terms of who gets vaccinated
who you know what's the order of the
queue
and then we've said that because
that means that there's you know we are
providing the vaccine to different
people at different times
the fair and right thing is to then
lift all the measures at once and for as
in
measures for all people at once um as
opposed to differentiate
by who has and hasn't had the vaccine
also because
we've got to put in place anyway for
things like international travel
and ability to show you've had the
vaccine but that isn't there
yet so we've decided to take an approach
where
the whether the whole of the whole
country moves
uh in one step at a time thank you very
much indeed
and next question is from laura
koonsberg at the bbc laura
thank you very much secretary of state
you've just told everybody that we are
on track with the vaccination but you
haven't mentioned this letter from the
nhs
which has just be come out which says
that there is a significant
reduction in the available supply and
that vaccine centers should stop
taking appointments for the whole month
of april what is going on
um and can you explain that shortage in
supply and what do you make of comments
from brussels today from the president
of the eu commission
about the uk should be sending vaccines
to the european union
thanks very much indeed well as i set
out in my in my remarks now that we've
opened up to the
50 and overs and then we're going to
really focus on
getting the vaccine to those who are the
most vulnerable
and of course we have a whole load of
second doses that we need to deliver
vaccine supply is always lumpy and we
regularly send out
technical letters to the nhs to explain
the
ups and downs of the supply over the
future weeks and what you're referring
to
is a standard one of those letters but
i've set out
the details in terms of how we can
deliver on the vaccine program
where we're on track and to meet the
target of
uh offering to all groups one to nine
uh on the 15th of april i mean if you
think about it it's currently
the middle of march and we've already
been able to open up the
uh to invite all over 50s
in and we need to make sure that we
reach just as high a proportion
as possible and you'll see in the letter
it refers to the focus that's needed
on the particularly vulnerable groups so
that's what we're going to be doing
to protect as many people as possible
turning to the issue
of supply from the european union of
course we work with our european
colleagues
all the time it's important to set out
that the oxford astrazeneca vaccine
was produced from research that was
funded by
the uk government tens of millions of
pounds
we set up the supply chain not just here
in the uk
but indeed we helped set up the supply
chain
uh in the eu
this vaccine is provided at cost to the
whole world so it's now being
manufactured
all the way around the world and we
legally signed a contract
for delivery of the first 100 million
doses
here for people in the uk as you would
expect
both to ensure that people in the uk can
get their jab and also because this is a
uk funded uk delivered vaccine but we're
very happy for others around the world
to be able to also manufacture it
at cost but at the same time as um
the president of the president vandalism
has said
she said there should not be
restrictions on the export of vaccines
by companies
where they are fulfilling contractual
responsibilities
and so the supply of vaccines from
eu production facilities to the uk is
indeed fulfilling contractual
responsibilities
and we fully expect those contracts to
be
delivered on
next question is from romely weeks at
itv
health secretary dominic cummings seems
to think that your department is to
blame for one of the biggest failings of
the pandemic the supply of ppe
and has nothing to do with one of its
biggest biggest successes
the vaccine roll out is that how you see
it
uh well the vaccines roll out has been a
huge team effort
and it's been an awful lot of people
pulling together to make it happen
obviously the the health department my
department also the vaccines task force
who've been absolutely brilliant and the
nhs
who have led the way in terms of the
delivery it's been a huge team
effort and the one of the striking
things
about being involved in the vaccine
rollout is that the spirit
is a positive mission driven can-do
spirit that we all share
and i think everybody involved in the
vaccine rollout would agree that we have
that
positive esprit de corps and that's the
best way to leave it
the next question from catherine sampson
at
stv thank you health secretary uh with
the vaccine rollout underway i think a
number of families are really
desperate to find out when they can
reunite with loved ones who live in
different uk
nations now yesterday the first minister
of scotland suggested
cross-border travel restrictions would
ease from around the 26th of april but
she didn't give a firm date so i'm just
wondering do you have a firm day and do
you think it's important
that the whole of the uk moves as one on
this and just on a separate note while
i'm here
just wondering what you made of your
former cabinet colleague david davis's
statement
in the comments yesterday was he right
to use parliamentary privilege to do it
thanks very much so on the first
question um
i very much look forward to at the
uh the all the restrictions on travel
within the uk
being removed i i i that we i've we've
set out
the when the english restrictions will
be removed and we'll
lift uh the uh stay at home
uh message as part of the roadmap out uh
and i've no doubt that within
a short few weeks uh everybody will be
free to travel around
the uk so long as we're able to keep
this progress going both the progress in
the uk wide vaccination effort
and keeping the number of cases under
control
when it comes to the what my colleague
david davis said in the house he's a
very experienced parliamentarian very
long-standing
um it is absolutely right and proper to
be able to use parliamentary privilege
in the way that he did parliamentarians
should give
due consideration before using
parliamentary privilege
and i'm sure that he did that um the
next question from jason groves at the
daily mail
thanks health secretary uh you skated
over uh
this issue of a falling vaccine supply
like it's some kind of technical issue
but
i mean reading this letter it feels like
a pretty big deal there are millions of
people
uh under 50 who are waiting for their
jabs and it looks like
that's going to be delayed can you tell
the under 50s when they're going to get
their jab can you also explain to them
why people in their 40s who want the jab
should have to wait while you try and
strong-arm
people uh older people who who don't
want it
so and can you also just tell us whether
this setback is going to have any impact
on
the lockdown timetable no
as i said the supply is always lumpy
and we are on course to
deliver the offer that everybody who's
aged 50 and above
will be able to get vaccinated by the
15th of april i recommit to that
today and of course you know these
supply schedules have
moved up and down throughout this whole
rollout it's
absolutely uh par for the course
and um it is a that that's why it's a
you know that is a normal operational
uh letter uh but the critical thing in
terms of the readers of the daily mail
is i can
assure readers of the daily mail that
there is
enough supply and we have the nhs across
the uk
ready to be able to deliver on the offer
of a vaccine to all over 50s by
the 15th of april um and
so what what about the under 50s when
are they going to get their jabs
looks like they're going to have to wait
at least an extra month yeah no
because we're committed to all adults
being able to get the
jab by the end of july
and we're on track to deliver on that
commitment
so it is we're making absolutely
fantastic progress
in the vaccination effort i'm delighted
we're able to open up
to millions more people today and
of course the you know the future
forecasts are always
uh lumpy and sometimes they go up and
sometimes they go down
but we've made these public commitments
and i'm absolutely uh
absolutely delighted with the team
because we're on track to meet them
thanks very much um and uh the next
question is from
aubry uh alegretti at the guardian
good afternoon mr hancock uh scientists
doctors the bereaved and now dominick
cummings have urged for a lessons
learned public inquiry
into the government's handling of
coronavirus why can't we have one now
are you concerned that the department of
health couldn't cope with the pressure
of public inquiry at the same time as
the pandemic
and to professor van tan has every
lesson that could have been learned so
far
been learned if not then wouldn't a
public inquiry ensure that happens
sooner rather than later well we're less
we're learning lessons all the time i
mean the
we're learning lessons from the vaccine
rollout you've just heard some of the
extra evidence uh we constantly look at
uh the actions that we take and work out
how we can
how we can make sure the response is as
good as possible
so that is happening all of the time
professor bantam
yes thank you for the question i mean i
think the timing of inquiries
is entirely a matter for ministers and
politicians it's not a matter
for physicians
personally would the an inquiry be
an unwelcome distraction for me
personally
at the moment when i'm very focused on
the vaccine
program and the vaccine program we might
need
in the autumn who knows i think it would
be
an extra burden that wasn't necessary
is looking back on what you did and
whether you could do
things better a function of medicine
in terms of the clinical audit that
happens in every
gp surgery and every nhs trust up and
down the land
yes it is will lessons be learned in due
course i am sure lessons will emerge
uh thanks very much uh final question is
from emily ashton from bloomberg emily
hello and for matt hancock i just wanted
to ask you say that the vaccination
targets will still be met
is there any scope then to bring forward
the dates of the roadmap
freezing lockdown or are they absolutely
the earliest dates possible
and for mr hancock and professor van tam
if possible
as more people are vaccinated and data
is showing that more and more people
are out and about despite these rules in
place
some older people are meeting people
indoors now they've been vaccinated
you see people playing football in the
parks at the weekend what do you say to
those people
tempted to break restrictions once
they've been vaccinated
and is there a risk of a possible third
wave
as we're seeing in other european
countries like italy
uh thanks very much i i mean on the
second question
going and playing football with your own
family in the parks is absolutely fine
uh and always has been so i i'm not sure
that's a
a piece of evidence that we should take
for people breaking the rules in fact
i'd say that my both what we measure and
my experience of being out and about is
that people are
being unbelievably uh supportive of the
rules and
and doing their bit i think that's um i
think it's
i think it's terrific how the british
people have have uh risen to this
challenge that we've all faced um
and um jbt i don't know if you've got
anything to add
yes thank you i have um two
two key science points people should
remember
that it takes quite a while for
antibodies
to become measurable in the bloodstream
after vaccination
certainly 14 days in in the younger age
groups
almost certainly 21 days or more in the
older age groups
but given the data that i've seen and
perhaps
professor ramsey will comment further on
this that
vaccine effectiveness after the first
dose
continues to increase beyond the 21 day
mark
clearly there is something going on
about
further maturation of the immune
response and greater protection
so you're not protected the moment
you've had the vaccine
it may be several weeks and you still
then require a second dose
before you are optimally protected
nevertheless i understand and i you get
it in my emails about can i go and see
x or y now i've had the vaccine
you know clinically once properly and
fully vaccinated
it is you know you are materially safer
but my message to everybody is look
let's try and
get out of where we are through the
successful use of vaccines
once can we just do it properly once
so please hold the line
just a little bit longer and we're only
talking a few more months
just hold the line because it will get
better
thanks very much dr ramsey yes i mean i
think it's
it's not just about yourself of course
with vaccination it's about protecting
others and of course
uh we want as high level of protection
as possible before we really want people
to start
behaving more as they as they used to so
i think our message is quite clear
um you know once you've had your vaccine
it'll take a while
please don't change your change your
behavior try and carry on
as much as you can keeping to the rules
keeping the distance
and avoiding unnecessary contact
thanks very much indeed yes
about the dates for unlocking the road
map are those dates set in stone
as the earliest possible dates yes
they're set out in the roadmap um
and the reason for those dates is to
give five weeks between steps so that we
can see the effect
of each step uh before making a decision
after four weeks with a week to go as to
whether we're able to take the next step
it's a it's a cautious but we hope
irreversible path and the effectiveness
of the vaccine that
dr ramsey set out today gives me
increased confidence
that we're going to be able to walk down
that road
as set out in the road map and um
we can see that the vaccines are making
people safe
and saving lives and we're on track on
the vaccine side
and we've seen the cases coming down
critically we're seeing the number of
hospitalizations
and deaths falling very sharply and that
is good news for us all
thanks very much indeed